hello everyone and welcome to another
very impressive game from round five of
this year's Norway chess also classical
time format Fabiano caruana who's been
leading the tournament uh well with uh
with such a lead even if he loses the
days around it does not matter he will
still remain in the lead his opponent is
the former 2800 player mamidyarov and uh
this game is uh is immaculate you guys
will see what I mean by this and for
those of you wondering uh I've seen this
question being posted in a couple of my
videos uh these are the the highest
ratings ever achieved in chess so there
you have it uh Magnus Carlsen uh highest
rating was achieved in 2014 28-89 so he
actually almost reached 2 900. uh Fabi
also as you can see uh was uh uh uh 2851
also in 2014 seems like a lot of players
just had their Peak ratings in 2014 but
the second place is still occupied by
Gary casparo with 2856 then you have
aronyan Levon with 28 35 then the vessel
into Paul 2026 then mamidyar of 28-26
also as you can see a 2800 player
Western was also 2800 uh this year was
2800 Maxine was 2800 he car was 2800 uh
Vladimir comedy dingler and uh
giri so only 15 players ever in the
history of the world have achieved a
classical rating of 2800 and uh also uh
you can see uh Yani Publishers
carp of 27.90 and then even Bobby
Fischer 27.89 but that was over 50 years
ago 51 years ago Fisher had a rating of
27.89 uh I mean when the ratings were
much much lower and he was like 100 and
something rating points high rated then
spicy when he was playing against him
for the title so there we have it just
uh throwing it out there as I've seen a
lot of discussion about this but now
let's check out the game uh you know
what Fabi is capable of you will now see
what Mama Jara table of so Fabi has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to
see for he goes for the English opening
we have Pawn to E5 and not Knight the C3
as usual we will have the Four Knights
of the English Knight the F6 Knight F3
Knight to C6 and Ponte e for the
nimsovich variation of the Four Knights
of the English Bishop to C5 and now
Knight captures on E5 so this is all
very standard stuff we've seen it the
Knight captures spawn to D4 attacks the
bishop and the Knight Bishop to B4 and
not D captures an E5 we have Knight
captures on e4 and queen to F3 and now
Knight captures on C3 is the most
popular move here but Shah goes for Pawn
to D5 and okay Fabi of course knows
Theory Bishop to E2 we have Pawn to D4
attacking the
uh paint piece but this also loses the
Knight on a E4 so Queen captures an E4 D
captures on C3 and both players castles
and safety so castles castle spawn to A3
chases away the bishop but first a nice
a nice sufficient to uh C captures on B2
Bishop captures and Bishop to C5 and
here there is a game where Rook after D1
was played but Fabi plays Bishop to D3
and as Bishop to D3 is the top move
recommended by the engine uh you well we
can pretty uh safely say that Fabi was
not thrown out of his comfort zone or
you know surprised in the opening uh by
Shah in this game and of course as of
move 14 we have a completely new game so
mamidarov is uh definitely playing with
fire here allowing Fabi this beautiful
Bishop pair to be pointed like this at
the black king and you don't really have
options here your only move is G6 other
than this you're getting checkmated so
G6 and finally goes for it pawn to E6
looks like a pawn sacrifice in order to
uh free up the the dark Square Bishop's
diagonal but you can't really capture
this Pawn for example in Bishop captures
Queen E5 and you're getting checkmated
you can't play F6 because Queen captures
on E6 and the F captures and E6 isn't uh
much better I mean still Queen to E5 and
if Queen to E7 okay guarding against
Checkmate you allow all sort of nasty
checks here now Queen characters on H7
with checking the E8 and now Bishop
captures on G6 uh you are getting
absolutely destroyed here so instead
after E6 uh just Queen t7 by momentarov
and now F captures uh sorry a rook after
E1 uh adding more uh Firepower to the E
file uh we have Pawn to A5 not really
worried about anything here and queen to
F4 we have Pawn to F6 now
uh no longer you have to worry about all
the tension here and okay a couple of
moves ago
um uh yes instead of Rook fte1 let's say
or maybe you were thinking Queen to E5
why not go for checkmate because then F6
just solves everything so that's the
reason why it wasn't played so here
Queen F4 F6 now Bishop to E4 uh putting
pressure on this diagonal not allowing
B6 and Bishop to B7 because of course
the mommy are would also enjoy putting
his Bishops there uh Rook to A6 now
attacking the E6 Square three times and
you will uh win that pawn eventually and
you could consider something like Bishop
to D5 sure it's uh it's uh definitely an
idea but five he goes for Rook a to D1
and now Rook to D6 uh capturing uh of
course you can do this bishop captures
an E6 but it's gonna be very tricky
Bishop captures on B7 attacks the rookie
Rook B6 attacks both of the Bishops here
now Bishop to D5 puts pressure on the E6
bishop and now Queen F7 and look at this
uh Bishop to D4 same your Bishop there
you will play Bishop capture Sunday for
Rook capture Sunday for and now Bishop
captures on D5 Rook captures on D5 and
it's a perfectly fine position for both
okay
um sharks King is a bit uh you know uh
more loose here with the f and g Pawn
being pushed forward uh but should be
should be perfectly perfectly fine
instead Rook the D6 was played and now
we have a trade Rook captures on D6
Bishop captures and D6 attacks the queen
and Fabi moves it to the H4 with Pawn to
C6 now stopping uh Bishop to D5 and here
we have Bishop to D3 by Fabi defending
the pawn on E6 uh the The crucial uh
move to consider here was Queen to H6
this prevents Bishop captures on A3
because it's very hard to actually
defend that pawn uh because if you go
after it now then you get destroyed just
Bishop captures an A3 Queen captures and
now they spawn to E7 move uh sorry about
that it seems the uh the the mailman is
here I'll just
uh sorry about that the mailman was
already here so I didn't think he'd show
up again but uh what are you gonna do uh
yeah so if E7 uh Rook the E8 would be
played and then this bishop captures on
G6 is just winning in pretty much all of
the lines if now Rook capture 77 how do
you defend here I mean you're gonna get
checkmated through captures on E7 uh
there's even Bishop captures on H7 with
the check and now if Rook captures the
queen to G6 with the check and now I
have to Rook to G7 it's just game over
Rook to E8 you have to block with the
queen uh only move and after Queen uh
fade you're just gonna capture Rook
captures King captures Queen captures on
F6 and of course the queen will beat the
bishop end of The Rook uh so that's that
uh the thing is after Queen to H6 you
will be able to play Queen to G7 and
that's uh well could be one of the
reasons why Fabi decided against this
queen to H6 idea altogether uh now you
you for example if you go back then a
shock can also go back if you repeat
Queen H6 uh you might even play
something like Bishop D5 uh even allow
the doubling here or not in the doubling
but the messing up of the pawn structure
in front of the black king for example
H4 Queen G7 Queen back the E3 Queen F6
um you know uh you will capture an E6
next it's perfectly fine uh for both
white and black but uh here Fabi played
Bishop to D3 and now Chuck just captures
the pawn bishop captures an A3 Bishop
captures Queen captures and now he asks
Fabi what are you uh planning next uh
Queen to G3 Fabi prepares Bishop
captures on G6 if
uh if it will be possible but uh mummy
just allows it uh he didn't play Pawn to
F5 Pont F5 seems like such a nice move
you I mean you make the light Square
Bishop useless and you don't care uh
there's no dark Square Bishop so you
won't get
um any problems along this diagonal and
uh it's hard to say why he decided
against it but he played Rook to E8 and
he basically invites Fabi to play Bishop
captures on G6 because now especially
with the Rook not guarding F7 uh it's
just a move you have to play Just Bishop
captures and G6 check and of course you
if you trade Queens right away then you
throw in a nice Bishop to F7 check first
so Rook captures on E6 this was a
momentaro's idea or of course if you
capture then just Queen captures and G6
and you get checkmated that doesn't
really matter what you do if you're
looking to fade then a queen to F7 would
check if you go to H then you lose the
Rook with check and then again you get
the checkmated so instead Rook captures
an E6 uh Bishop back to D3 opening up a
discovery to the black king and also not
allowing the trade to happen King the h8
and now Rook the D1 and all of a sudden
fabi's position just became a little bit
passive he's down material uh okay on
the plus side he did open up the black
king but will he be able to attack the
black king so here we have Rook to D6 uh
sorry uh Queen to D6 offering a queen
trade and now Queen to F3 of course
avoiding the trade uh and now how do you
continue here Queen to E7 of course
going for Rook to E1 check uh Bishop to
F1 not allowing it to come with track
and now
uh Rook D1 would be pointless you would
just capture and after the queen
captures you play Queen captures on F6
and you have at least a Perpetual so
Rook D5 instead we have Pawn to H4
creating some breathing room for the
black for the white king uh Bishop to E6
and now Rook the D4 now a nice Rook lift
preparing to get the Rook into the
action uh also defending the C4 Pawn now
comes Rook to E1 and now uh well Fabi
does not have all that many all that
many playable moves Queen to D3 is one
idea that you might consider going for
Rook to DH check also being able to play
Queen to D2 Fabi decides to go for Queen
to C3 he attacks The Rook on E1 and also
kind of pressures this diagonal but the
shark just goes Bishop back to G8 and
now you don't really have a way of uh
attacking the pawn here if you play Rook
to F4 Queen to E5 it's not a problem so
instead Queen to D2 was played now
hoping to get some Rook lifts in but now
Queen to E5 we have Rook to d8 uh and
queen to A1 just going after after that
Bishop on F1 and 5V plays Queen to D3
here and this is another sub-optimal
move by Fabi uh he definitely had a few
this game uh but you know on the on the
plus side mamidaro is playing a
brilliant game he's he's playing with
engine like Precision uh here King to H2
is actually the move Fabi should play
point is you cannot capture on F1
because if you capture on F1 it's just a
force to draw Rook captures and Jade
King captures and now Queen to d8 with
check and it looks like you might be
able to get out of it but whatever you
play White does have a Perpetual One
Fine Line uh that where you actually
allow the black king to go down the
board like the queen to D7 checking G6
Queen d8 with checking the F5 G4 with
checking captures and queen to E4 uh now
you control this diagonal and you have a
Perpetual Queen a king to H5 you're
gonna capture here with checking G4 it's
uh it's a force draw and all the other
lines uh end up in a a three-fold
repetition maybe Fabi thought that he
was still playing for the win uh it's
hard to say but he was incredibly low on
time he like he's been he had like 10
seconds on the clock you know just
playing an increment so he had to be
fast Queen to D3 was played and now just
Queen to B1 uh threatening uh to trade
queens and also if you move the queen
from this diagonal You're Gonna Lose the
bishop on F1 in order not to play this
uh terrible end game after captures
captures uh Fabi just decided to play
Rook capture sanjayed he gives up the
exchange and now after King captures
Sanjay now Queen to d8 with check hoping
that he probably still has the Perpetual
but now it is different King to G7 we
have Queen to C7 with check uh hoping to
get some action along this diagonal a
king to G6 and now Queen to G3 with
check we have King to F5 and now Queen
to H3 with check of course he will run
towards the queen side King D5 Queen to
G3 checking D6 and now Queen to G8 with
check King 37 Queen to F7 with Chuck
King to see it and now King to H2 uh
hoping for Rook captures on F1 then okay
The Rook leaves the E file so you have
maybe better chances about Perpetual uh
but even though root captures on F1 is
winning shock will not even allow
himself to to maybe you know enter the
area where mistakes are possible he just
plays Queen to E4 and I mean of course
the position is completely winning
doesn't really matter what Fabi plays
Queen to G8 check with King to C7 King
to G1 defending the bishop here but just
Queen back to sorry not there that would
be weird the queen to D3 and next move
okay it's game over uh here five play
Queen to F7 check one last spite check
you know just for good measure King to
B6 and he was in this position animal 47
uh that Fabiano corwana resigned the
game and he Lo he loses his first
classical game in the tournament or or
even his uh his first encounter he
didn't lose in classical or Armageddon
so yeah absolutely incredible play by
Mommy Dr so it's not sloppy played bad
it's just that in those um a couple of
instances where Fabi could have played
the top engine move and maybe a
sub-optimal engine move uh you know it
was a Fabi responded with a sub-optimal
engine move and the momentar just played
the all the top moves uh he absolutely
crushed Fabi at this game and it's not
easy I mean that a position where we
discussed Queen to H6 uh if you
calculate all of this I mean you're you
you are a Madman so okay he missed this
he missed a couple of other ideas uh
took advantage of all of them and he
deals Fabi his first defeat in the
tournament and for those of you who
maybe missed my previous video here are
the uh standing so far he's still in the
lead because he was leading by more more
than three points after round four so
it's Fabi Hikaru alireza
Magnus Anish Wesley noderbeck and the
Aryan those are the the standings here
you have uh uh the uh the encounters
another but loses to go cash in
Armageddon Fabi loses the shocking
classical uh Wesley loses styleza in
Armageddon Hikaru defeated Atari in the
classical we've shown that game in the
previous video and the Magnus defeated
gookish also in Armageddon so yeah I
might throw one more game yesterday is
the rest day if you guys have any of
your own favorites from Armageddon uh
use hashtag suggestion and I will
definitely go over them and for those of
you who missed it yes Hikaru Nakamura is
the new world number two in classical
chess he overshadows uh alireza Fabiano
and anijigiri who are all you know
fairly close to each other some for for
raiding if a four to five rating a
difference absolutely incredible by
Hikaru who will be uh world number one
tomorrow after another run display it's
hard to say will Hikaru continue this
Onslaught or will it be someone else
we'll have to wait and see for now
Magnus is fairly safe up there with
28-41 uh but yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it brilliant brilliant
play by mamajaro just showing you why he
was a former 2800 player when he plays
he just he just you know he he plays
like a 2800. uh so yeah I really hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Mikhail sakar is David
Nicholas wolf and Andres Valley news for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular tournament until it finishes
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day